[Music]
welcome to the iron Lords podcast okay
we got started up but the Incredible
Hulk it is a we are told
we're on lamb engine stalling out here
but they are hiding they are being very
stealth --is-- acting like lord Cognito
we gonna find him rebel studios in the
building what's going on
real father
checking option
to walk in there it already
English dessert check it
feel like I'm heat with y'all these
coasts convention in a building
I feel getting close
I'm a girl
okay
oh we get hot we're getting high
I see the jim Starlin
I see here
the germ Starling but where is the wrong
lamb
we're on them says looking down the
corner but I see this is this is world
see right here he's got his head down I
believe but this is
the Infinity Gauntlet these are the
comics you've been watching look at this
great look at his great issue it's great
oh look at this snap we go right back
you're working you gonna come right back
we go see another legend oh there he is
this is what I came for we got another
legend the legendary the legendary he's
working right now but I'm gonna let him
work well let him work like a big big li
affinity gauntlet shirts the legend
every royal in this is this is this is
magic right now but Silver Surfer fiends
but look at the fear is lining up for
this man
get it in right now to give it a legit
all right this is the moment y'all
this is the moment and lord coquitos
been waiting for
still working
the legendary Ron Lim can I shake the
legends hand
the immortal silver the best silver sir
from you ever seen penciled an honor and
a privilege ILO podcast salute
the legendary jim Starlin y'all
the legendary jim Starlin thanos creator
can we say hi can we get the handshake
of the legend would it be possible for
Tainos to take off the glove for a
second he's working this is a lot of
people's childhood yeah gauntlet soccer
the legendary jim Starlin I love
podcasts the loop appreciate your work
man
much appreciated you saw it here first
bet it's legends in the building we got
TV man in the building dell computer CC
artis in the building
alright forget the flatscreen we don't
need flat-screen yes sir East Coast
comic-con in the house we're gonna wrap
it up we're gonna do some networking we
want to give you some first-hand
experience or we get behind the scenes
ILP ILP